vingt ans après sa création le film
culte de stanley kubrick orange
mécanique actuellement sur les écrans
tourner la tête des cinéphiles et des
adolescents 800 mille entrées en
quelques semaines un véritable phénomène
de société
kubrick visionnaire le talent du metteur
en scène américain adoptée par la
génération des années 90
roselyne febvre pendant jeu mécanique
était en fait celle bombe à retardement
le chef-d'oeuvre aux polluants de ce
remake et brief plus apparemment rien
perdu de son pouvoir
la violence est la matière première à
l'ess s'est cette fois que peint forme
les quatre équipiers du mal déguisés en
clown tragique ils tuent et violent
le sang est leur seule tache de couleur
dans ce monde ingrat
et
il ya 20 ans ce film était considéré
comme un séisme cinématographique d'une
violence inouïe presque insupportable
le film dépasse et me semble tout à fait
actuelle c'est pour ça que j'ai voulu
que ma fille puisse la revoir vivante
après avoir la même émotion
je ne peux pas encore parler discuter
avec elle je vais si ça coïncide avec
soi même ce que vous avez ressenti vous
en moi je trouve ça complètement démence
et je trouve ça vraiment super sais pas
comment dire
il y avait à tort je crois que ça
choquera mots j'ai pas vu je veux pas
faire voir mais ça me répondront pu
choquer j'en attends maintenant on a
tellement vu de scènes de violence au
cinéma il faut bien le dire que ces
scènes-là ya bien sûr des scènes
d'humiliation
l'individu dont on fait lécher les
bottes de l'autre bon enfin ça n'est pas
à mon avis choquant au point de ne pas
pouvoir supporter la partie du film
dirais que c'est commun on voit ça
souvent un télévision par contre la
deuxième partie m'a beaucoup choqué le
traitement qu'on lui inflige
c'est assez insupportable
violence est a perdu de son panache
c'est presque un bouillon fadasse face à
mad max ou terminator mais la violence
psychologique et intellectuel elle reste
intense et la force de ce film qui reste
un événement vingt ans après on
s'attendait un succès mais ce succès a
été très très au delà de nos espérances
on est très très contents à sa sortie ce
film était qualifié de visionnaire de
futuriste pendant un temps il a été l'un
des objets de culte du cinéma parce
qu'il a été aussi protégé par son
metteur en scène qui a toujours refusé
la diffusion de cassettes vidéo
c'était là aussi le trait de génie
visionnaire de stanley kubrick